- - Hot dog, frites au Montréal
PoPool Room, non ce n'est pas
dede la gastronomie,
mamais une rencontre avec
JeJean-Louis Rheault dont
leles cartes illustrées tapisset
leles murs de ce restaurant
plplus que centenaire de Montré.
- - Quand j'ai fait la nouvelle
cacarte de Montréal on l'a
afaffichée, puis...
- - Le patron aimait ça,
c'c'est ça, l'idée?
- - La carte de Tampa... oui,
j'j'ai des beaux souvenirs.
- - Des cartes réalisées
avavec son associé torontois
dedes années 80 qui ont marqué
lele début d'une longue carrière
dede cartographe-illustrateur
dodont le nom est probablement
plplus connu à Singapour,
enen Arabie saoudite ou
enen Colombie-Britannique que
dadans son pays natal. Tout jeu,
ilil était doué pour le dessin.
JEJEAN-LOUIS RHEAULT,
cacartographe-illustrateur
- - Je faisais des caricatures,
dedes espèces de petits "comics"
susur les professeurs.
- - Ce qui lui a valu quelques
enennuis. Une fois trouvée
sasa vocation, il s'est lancé.
- - Ma carte d'Alblbany, New Yok
a a été la première. Après, j'ai
étété à Genève. Bien oui, c'est
çaça, c'est la carte de Genève à
mama première vrai. Et puis j'ai
étété dans la Tribune de Genève.
CÇa les a surpris qu'un
QuQuébécois, avec l'accent et
totout, arrive à Genève, et puis
fafasse... Alors j'ai eu une trs
bebelle expérience.
- - Il trouve les commanditaires
etet les représentent.
- - Rolex, Piaget, c'est
YvYves Piaget lui-même.
- - Reste à ajouter ses petites
totouches personnelles,
huhumoristiques.
- - C'est ici que Tintin dans
l'l'Affaire Tournesol passe
papar la gare Cornavin.
- - Et histotoriques.
- - Il y a Lénine qui a séjourné
àà Genève et ainsi que Mussolin.
MuMussolini s'est fait expulser,
mmême! L'ironie, c'est que,
mamaintenant, ces cartes-là
dede Genève, elles se vendent
àà 500 francs suisses, c'est-à-
didire 700 $, parce que c'est
mamaintenant un item de nostalg.
- - Après Genève, Montréal, sure
mmême modèle de commanditaires.
- - Le Drapeau, Camillien Houde,
MéMédéric Martin. Et puis c'est
plplein de petits trucs comme ç.
IlIl y a un petit dessin de
WiWilliam Shatner, le capitaine
dede Star Trek, parce qu'il esté
àà Montréal.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
ChChamplain est là, qu'il admir.
- - Un de mes grand héros,
c'c'est Samuel de Champlain.
C'C'est lui qui a fait vraiment
lala première carte de l'Amériqe
dudu Nord.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - L'art est très ancien,
leles cartes étaient souvent
ilillustrées de monstres marins,
d'd'êtres fantastique,
dede cannibales.
- - Ceci va devenir Cape Cod,
avavec Boston. Et ceci va devenr
MaManhattan, c'est-à-dire New
YoYorkrk.
- - Jean-Louis a réalisé
dedes cartes commerciales,
totouristiques, industrielles
auaussi, comme celle des Grands
LaLacs. Un travail de moine
ququi commence à la main avec ue
esesquisse, comme celle des Gras
LaLacs, transposée ensuite dans
l'l'ordinateur pour la finition.
LeLe tiers supérieur de cette
cacarte de la vallée de l'Okanan
a a été faite toute à l'aquarel.
LeLe reste à l'ordinateur.
- - Ça prend beaucoup d'esquisss
auau crayon avant d'arriver au
dedessin à l'encre.
- - Ça vous prend combien de tes
popour faire une...
- - Ça, ça a pris au moins un a.
- - Un an, hein!
- - Oui! Oui!
- - Travailler dessus tous les
jojours...
- - Oui, oui, tous les jours.
L Le terrain, mettre une couch.
EnEnsuite, les routes, les arbr.
IlIl y a les édifices qui ont éé
dedessinés avec des détails
cocomme les voitures. Des fois,
memes cartes, elles ont comme
80800, 900, des fois 1000 couchs
didifférentes.
- - Il y a des projets en cours
enen Arizona. Après Santa Fe,
lele Lac Powell, la ville de Pae
etet puis une commande pour
teterritoire de la nation Navaj.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
UnUne carte des Émirats arabes
ununis pour l'anniversaire du
ShSheikh l'a amené à l'Arabie
sasaoudite et à la Mecque,
ouoù il a illustré les étapes
dudu Hajj dans le détail.
UnUn séjour prolongé
àà Anchorage, en Alaska,
àà cause du 11 septembre 2001
l'l'a conduit à faire de sa care
unun casse-tête. Oui, de nos
jojours, les cartes routières
sosont un peu démodées, mais pas
leles siennes.
- - Quand l'Internet est arrivé,
leles gens ont dit : ah,
lala cartographie sur papier,
c'c'est mort. Mais, le GPS c'est
popour montrer comment se rendr.
MaMais une carte, c'est illustr,
c'c'est pourquoi veut-on se rene
llà.
- - Jean-Louis Rheault n'est pas
prprès d'arrêter. Il a des projs
enen tête, à commencer par un
rarafraichissement de sa carte
dede Montréal, qui a bien changé
dedepuis la dernière fois.
♪ ♪ ♪